et lors tous avant que la vidéo commence
je souhaitais prendre quelques secondes
pour vous inviter à me rejoindre sur
instagram c'est un réseau que j'utilise
de plus en plus et que j'aime beaucoup
donc voilà vous êtes tous conviés
bref bonne vidéo
pendant la préparation
horie une date est tombé c'est le 8
juillet 2022 la sortie prévue pour blake
panthères 2 wakanda forever c'est un
épisode marvel que j'attends énormément
1 franchement je vais pas vous mentir le
premier à marquer clairement la firme
est forcément bas on attend du lourd
pour ce black panthères de la suite
néanmoins la récente disparition de
chadwick bosman l'acteur de tshala le
lac panthères fut une énorme surprise
pour tout le monde
obligeant à un remodelage du film et du
scénario car évidemment le rôle de
tshala ne sera normalement pas redonné
il est une sorte de paradoxe le sujet
est très complexe du coup car tout est
chamboulé et pourtant bas le film ne
sort que dans un an c'est très peu enfin
voila cela faisait un moment que je
souhaitais vous parlez de black
panthères 2 et là du coup j'estime que
c'est le moment de le faire
alors bienvenue dans ce nouveau trois
théories commençons sans tarder
s'il y a bien un mystère concernant
black panther 2 c'est son antagoniste
car après tout cela reste la base d'un
film de super héros et malgré cet
événement tragique et le remaniement du
scénario du film nous auront bel et bien
un vilain présent dans le film
et même si nous n'avons aucune
déclaration sur ce dernier il y a moyen
de déceler quelque chose marvel aime
beaucoup les détails et c'est justement
dans avengers endgame que la réponse
pourrait s'y trouver
cinq ans après le snap de thanos les
avengers font des meetings régulière
pour essayer d'améliorer la situation et
résumer ce qu'ils ont fait et où repéré
pendant cet entretien au collier la
cheffe des doha mais la dja est présente
et cette dernière révèle quelque chose
de très intéressant
apparemment le rwanda aurait senti une
série de tremblements de terre sous
marin proche du continent africain au
collier affirme ensuite que le wakanda
ne compte rien faire de spécial car
justement c'est loin et situé sous la
mer donc bas qui s'en fout quoi au
premier abord cela ne semble pas si
important que ça pourtant ce détail est
tellement gros qu'il est impossible à
ignorer
il s'agit à très fortes chances de namor
et de l' empire d'atlantis tout d'abord
dans une question de logique et de
comment c'est amener ce n'est pas
n'importe qui qui annonce la nouvelle du
tremblement de terre
c'est au collier et c'est très important
pour comprendre la finesse de ce détail
dans avengers endgame tchalla et xuri
ont disparu à cause du snap
c'est donc en quelque sorte au collier
qui devient la représentante du wakanda
auprès des avengers au collier symbolise
le wakanda et c'est eux qui ont
découvert ces tremblements de terre ce
qui veut dire que cette découverte est
liée aux wakanda et donc justement
l'avenir du pays pour revenir plus
précisément sur namor il est le
personnage le plus sensé pour être levé
l'un du film ce dernier est le roi
d'atlantis un royaume situé sous les
eaux et donc dirigeants du peuple
atlante évidemment on retrouve tout le
côté légende de la cité perdue de
l'atlantide
mais le plus intéressant est que dans
les comics namor et donc atlantis puis
xala et le wac en dha sont de très
grands rivaux et ont vécu beaucoup de
confrontations dans un délire
d'adaptation de l'histoire originelle
pour les films black panther 1 nous
amène l'ouverture du pays au monde avec
notamment la création de centres dead
internationaux le partage de
connaissances et cetera bref ils ne
vivront plus véritablement cacher sauf
que ces derniers sont propriétaires de
la météorite de vibranium tombé il ya
des milliers d'années une ressource
convoitée par énormément de monde et qui
pourrait se faire savoir rapidement
notamment par namor concernant le
scénario on se doute bien que namor
n'attaquerait pas le wac en date
gratuitement il doit y avoir un but
précis ce dernier n'est pas un véritable
méchant à proprement parler mais un roi
qui a des conflits avec le wakanda étant
donné que les donations son rival dans
les comics nous pourrions supposer que
leur histoire soit lié à la météorite de
vibranium dans le sens où pourquoi pas
le peuple
atlante à convoiter la météorite et
s'est fait chasser à l'époque par
batchenga l'ancêtre de tshala le rwanda
étant dans une période de crise avec la
menace de la tacc du peuple atlante
nous pourrions être témoin de
l'émergence d'une personnalité apte à
diriger le wakanda suite à la
malheureuse disparition de chadwick
bosman dont le rôle de tshala ne sera
pas réattribué met d'ailleurs comment
pourrait se traduire l'arrivée d'un
nouveau black panthères
dans l'histoire du wakanda il est dit
qu'une météorite depuis brax niyum est
tombé sur terre modifiant les propriétés
de toute la flore locale ce sont des
siècles plus tard que plusieurs tribus
ont décidé de s'installer dans la région
et se sont affrontés pour avoir la
source de ce vibranium c'est batchenga
devenu le premier black panthères qui
par le biais d'une vision de la déesse
vaste a été guidé à la fleur en forme de
coeur pour unifier les tribus une fleur
qui à cause du vibranium a muté et qui
permet donc à qui la consomment d'avoir
des capacités surhumaines de par la
tradition instaurée dans le pays suite
aux actions de bashung à chaque nouveau
roi un géreur à la plante afin de
devenir le nouveau black panthères sauf
que plusieurs problèmes existent
concernant la fleur et cette mécanique
d'en consommer pour avoir des super
pouvoirs
déjà il n'y en a plus à cause d'eux
qu'ils m'ont gher dans un délire de
devenir le seul et unique roi avoir des
pouvoirs endja dacca a brûlé les fleurs
de coeur après en avoir ingéré alors
néanmoins il est possible qu il en
repousse un jour vu que toute la flore
du pays a été modifié à cause du
vibranium voir que d'autres plantes
possèdent ces effets aussi voir même que
l'humain arrive à recréer c'est même
fortement probable ça mais il existe un
plus gros souci c'est que n'importe qui
peut manger cette plante et avoir des
pouvoirs
malgré les traditions du wakanda et le
respect de la royauté par ses habitants
qu'ils m'ont girl à prouver n'importe
qui peut s'imposer et avoir des pouvoirs
pire encore avec l'ouverture du wakanda
et de l'apport de leurs connaissances au
reste du monde
et si des ennemis de la nation mettez la
main sur cette plante ou une formule
permettant de la regret ce que je veux
vous faire comprendre c'est que la fleur
de coeur propose une dissonance avec
l'unicité du black panthère et la
royauté qui l'entourent
c'est exactement comme pour le délire du
sérum du super soldat
nous avions à la base steve rogers puis
s'est rajouté d'autres soldats cachés
les soldats de l'hiver comme béquille et
au final nous nous sommes retrouvés avec
un grand nombre de personnes ayant du
sérum du super-soldat en eux comme john
walker carly et son groupe et cetera
si des étrangers du wakanda ou même des
habitants du pays arrive à regret la
fleur qu'est ce qui différenciera le
black panthères soit le roi du wakanda
des autres êtres humains dans un délire
que marvel à de vouloir casser les codes
instauré et nous montrer des passations
de pouvoirs et si la recette pour
devenir le nouveau dirigeant du wakanda
changé c'est évidemment une question qui
m'a trotté en tête suite à l' annonce de
marvel de ne pas remplacer le rôle de
tshala incarné par le regretté chadwick
bosman à la manière de la reprise du
rôle de captain america par sam
gravitant pendant un moment autour du
bouclier symboles de la reprise de la
fonction ce dernier nous a prouvé qu'il
n'avait pas forcément besoin d'avoir de
super pouvoirs pour unifier et réussir
et tout comme steve rogers dans engament
qui a réussi à glo 1 grâce à mjolnir
malgré une condition de super-soldat
vieillissant et si le nouveau black
panthères devait brandir sky braqueurs
pour symboliser son règne et son unicité
pour la faire simple sky breaker est une
sorte d'épée en vibranium créé par
batchenga le premier roi du wakanda à la
découverte de ce qu'était le vibranium
justement c'est un petit peu l'artefact
l arme ultime du wakanda transpirant de
symbolisme et de respect dans les comics
étant donné l'unicité d'une telle arme
nous pourrions faire face comme solution
de secours dans la tradition rwandaise
que pour définir un nouveau roi ou
nouvelle reine or lignée royale les
prétendants au trône devrait ramener le
sky breaker et brandir cette épée pour
être élu un cas tout à fait inédit
puisque la lignée de tshala perdure
depuis le tout premier roi batchenga
mais même si la finalité serait un
retour de kim hông heures pour reprendre
le flambeau
ou bien que schori prennent le relais
cet ep permettrait aux blacks panthères
de ce brave en tant que héros et de ne
pas stagner laissant au fil du temps la
fleur de coeur derrière lui c'est une
politique importante pour marvel studios
et en particulier pour cette phase iv
plein de passation de pouvoir sam n'a
peut-être pas le sérum du super soldat
mais l'alliance du bouclier et de ses
elles font de lui un héros redoutable
rwanda était peut-être la petite
sorcière des avengers mais elle est
aujourd'hui la scarlet witch débordante
de magie du chaos
spider man était peut-être la petite
araignée du quartier peter possède
aujourd'hui son spider sense et la
technologie est dit
thor était peut-être le dieu du tonnerre
aujourd'hui il est en possession de
stormbreaker une arme divine
bref nous pouvons aller très loin comme
ça mais chaque héros doit y passer
passation de pouvoir ou pas sky breaker
ctp ultime du peuple ougandais qui ne
peut se briser
ni s'émousser permettrait à son
possesseur de devenir le véritable
symbole attendu par la nation
si le marvel cinématiques universe nous
a bien fait comprendre une chose c'est
qu'ils font ce qu'ils veulent des
personnages on ne le rappellera jamais
assez mais même si l'histoire de base
est calquée sur les comics il y a un
énorme paramètres de réadaptation des
personnages des intrigues de l'univers
et c'est le cas avec bucky alias le loup
blanc que j'estime être important à
mentionner
originellement sergent bucky barnes
l'est devenu le soldat de l'hiver une
véritable machine à tuer c'est dans la
scène post générique de black panthères
que le nom de white wolf sera mentionnée
pour la première fois nous montrant un
bug qui apaisé scène post générique qui
sera développée via falcone et le soldat
de l'hiver où nous sommes témoins du
long travail instauré par lés wakanda
pour délivrer bucky de son lavage de
cerveau et on n'en sait pas plus alors
que pourtant bas il ya beaucoup de
symboles et de matières à traiter
tout d'abord pour les non connaisseurs
white wolf existe dans les comics c'est
un enfant qui a survécu à un crash
d'avion atterri au wakanda ce dernier
fut recueilli par chaka le roi du
wakanda et le père de tshala l'enfant
ayant à peu près le même âge que le fils
du roi
les deux ont grandi ensemble sauf qu une
jalousie naquit chez le white wolf
envers tchalla dont l'avenir promettait
de grandes choses ce qui a fait de lui
l'un des ennemis du black panther
voilà pour faire simple c'est ça une
histoire très éloigné de ce que nous
avons dans le mc hugh et pourtant white
wolf rime tout d'abord avec nouvelle
identité pour bucky barnes grâce aux à
kandahar et leur aide
bucky est aujourd'hui un nouvel homme
est un homme libre il a été en quelque
sorte
recueilli par le pays comme l'enfant qui
a survécu au crash de l'avion et c'est
là que c'est intéressant car on a
tendance à l'oublier mais beck qui a
passé près de six années
wakanda et comme nous l'a montré la
série de falcone et le soldat de l'hiver
ce dernier est lié au pays les doha à
millas jay retrouve sa trace facilement
il reconnaît la trace
ces dernières ils lui ont donné un bras
dont il semble encore ignorer tous les
secrets ils livrent même ses mots au wac
hand à la fin de la série alors qu'il
était dans une autre prison et se permet
même de demander un service odorat me
dadjé bref la relation entre bucky et le
wac en dha est très particulière et on
est loin d'avoir toutes les cartes en
main ce qui est clair c'est que buck qui
possède une sorte d'allégeance pour ces
derniers même si au départ tchalla a
recueilli bucky suite à la demande de
steve rogers un de ses grands alliés 2
qui peut être un atout et un allié de
taille pour le pays
nous savons par le biais du premier film
que le wakanda possède des espions
situés partout dans le monde
bucky pourrait en être clairement un
suite à la bataille finale de and games
le wakanda aurait pu appuyer le retour
de barnes aux états unis et lui
permettre d'être gracié pour que ce
dernier puisse servir d'informateurs
c'est d'ailleurs ce que ces actions
traduisent durant la série de falcon une
fonction d'espions mise en place depuis
déjà possiblement un bon moment puisque
tchalla lui fait confiance doit donner
un bras en vibranium lui demande de
combattre à ses côtés pendant la guerre
du wakanda digne finity war et on se
doute bien que dans le fond ils ne font
pas ça non plus gratuitement de qui
restera toujours fidèle au wac en daim
par rapport à blake brandt r2 et la
série prévu sur le rwanda qui sortira
sur dix n'est plus nous pourrions faire
face au début du véritable white wolf en
tenue réf bug qui va devenir le
personnage clé liant les avengers avec
le wac en dha et j'aimerais également
calé un petit mot concernant vision son
retour dans one la vision nous a montré
que ce dernier a perdu tout sentiment
toutes ces émotions néanmoins il a
retrouvé ses souvenirs
le white vision pourrait vouloir
retrouver ses origines pour comprendre
qui il était vraiment sauf qu'étant
donné que tony stark est mort que banner
n'est pas non
un expert et a même tourné la page
souris est la seule aujourd'hui à savoir
véritablement comment fonctionne vision
ce qui voudrait dire que nous pourrions
avoir le retour de vision dans black
panthères de voir une scène post
générique
merci à tous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout le sujet n'était pas si
simple en vrai un plaque dentaire est un
monument de marvel studios et j'espère
vous avoir proposé des théories
intéressantes pour la suite en tout cas
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à me le
faire savoir en laissant un pouce bleus
en vous abonnant à la chaîne en laissant
un petit commentaire avec vos idées vos
théories 1 c'est toujours un
un plaisir de vous lire on va s'arrêter
là a très vite pour une prochaine vidéo
et que le lionheart soit avec vous allez
ciao tout le monde
[Musique]
oh